the UK has the worst inflation in
Western Europe it's also higher than in
Japan Canada and the US that means the
money you take home at the end of every
month is worth less and people are
really feeling the pinch
now we already know we're in a cost of
living crisis with things like energy
and food prices affected by the war in
Ukraine and dare we say it brexit the
chancellor Jeremy Hunt says his
government has a plan to deal with it
and if we're going to reduce that
pressure on families it's absolutely
essential that we stick to that plan and
we see it through so that we halve
inflation this year as the Prime
Minister has promised but for now we're
going to have to suffer through what Mr
Hunt himself admits could be a very
difficult period
I'm Sally Lockwood and on today's Sky
News Daily we're looking at what's
making inflation so high what it means
for all of us in crucially when it may
start to come down
to do that I'm going to be talking to
Skye's Finance expert but first our
business correspondent gurpreet no one
is with me
so Capri the UK has the highest
inflation of any country in western
Europe the highest of any country in the
G7 let's start with the very Basics just
outline exactly what inflation is so
inflation is a measure of how quickly
prices are rising in the economy it's
the rate of change rather than the price
level so when we say inflation is
slowing that doesn't mean that prices
are coming down that means they're just
Rising a bit more slowly than they were
the previous month okay so in light of
that why is inflation so much higher
here higher than any other country in
western Europe and any other country in
the G7 why is that uh yeah so I think
firstly it's important to point out that
we're not alone in suffering with
inflation countries across the world are
battling with inflation because a lot of
causes are out of our control we know
we're suffering from an energy crisis
because of the war in Ukraine we've also
had Harvest failures in parts of Europe
which is affecting our food supply so
we're all battling with inflation but as
you correctly pointed out
we're really facing the brunt of this
and that's partly because we do have
some unique attributes that have exposed
us to the crisis we use a lot of gas to
heat our homes in the UK versus other
countries uh in the world which means
when wholesale gas prices leapt earlier
in the year we were really vulnerable to
that but that doesn't mean all of our
problems are imported we also have
problems at home and one of them is our
really tight labor market so after the
pandemic a lot of people left the world
of work a lot of migrants went home
brexit of course didn't help with that
but we also have a lot of people who are
too sick to work and we have students
who are prioritizing their studies over
working now a tight labor market means
employees have to pay higher wages in
order to attract staff and wage growth
in the UK has been pretty robust and
when businesses have to put up wages
they then often part prices to cover
their increased costs and so there
therein is the wage price spiral that
economists like to talk about there's
some debate over whether we're really
there yet but it's certainly something
that the bank of England is repeatedly
warning us about and goes some way to
explaining why we're suffering from
higher inflation than in other countries
and why hasn't inflation gone down as
much as some economists were predicting
it's still stubbornly above 10 percent
despite forecasts that it would drop
down to single digits in March
yeah economists are having some trouble
forecasting inflation and that's partly
because of the big drivers in this are
really volatile items like food and
energy prices and they can swing wildly
from month to month and that's why
economists are really struggling to
accurately forecast inflation
based on that I can tell you why
inflation is higher than many thought
it's because food prices are still
stubbornly high why is food inflation so
high a lot of people asking if it's to
do with brexit brexit certainly plays a
part in it there are a lot of reasons
why food prices are high firstly there's
a supply problem we've had Harvest
failures in parts of Spain and in Africa
which means we're struggling with our
supply of fruit and vegetables but also
fertilize the costs and energy costs
which we rely on in the production of
food have been high for a really long
time packaging costs are high transport
costs have been high and that's partly
on the latter point is partly because of
problems at borders which has been
exacerbated by brexit now of course the
government has pledged to harm inflation
by the end of the year and so this won't
be good news to them but how is that
looking in terms of a Target yeah it's
not good news for the government which
wants to really bring inflation down
it's made it its main policy aim but
most economists think that inflation is
still on track to fall considerably it
also means that the bank of England is
probably going to act pretty
aggressively to bring inflation down we
think that they're probably going to
raise interest rates now next month in
the last few days financial markets
certainly weren't sure about whether the
bank would move but now it's looking
like an almost dead sir that they're
going to have to raise interest rates
now you've already kind of touched on
why raising interest rates helps with
inflation could you just explain the
mechanics of that for us yeah so policy
makers raise interest rates because they
want to dampen all the pressure in the
economy the inflationary pressure in the
economy when we don't have the supply to
meet the demand in the economy you want
to stop people spending and you want
them to start saving their money instead
so higher interest rates do that they
incentivize you to lock your money away
and to not spend it and they do that
because it increases the cost of
borrowing and incentivizes saving so
that's how interest rates work that's
how they dampen demand in the economy
and hopefully dampen uh inflation now
there is some debate about how effective
interest rates are when inflation is
being driven by Supply factors so things
like the energy crisis it wasn't to do
with too much demand in the economy it
was to do with something that interest
rates don't really have much control
over something external exactly
but there are signs in the UK that we do
have this domestically generated
inflation problem so economists look at
something called core inflation that's
when you strip away some of the external
problems that we've been facing like
food and energy and when we strip those
away we can see that inflation the core
inflation rate is still at 6.2 percent
it's high and Economist this month
thought it was going to come down it
didn't that means that interest rates
Could Be an Effective tool and are an
effective tool to dampen some of that
inflationary pressure
okay gabri just wait there we'll be back
with you in a minute but let's speak to
co-founder of financial advice website
naus and Sky's household Finance expert
Greg Marsh Greg thanks so much for
joining us thanks for having me just
what does it impact the most I mean the
first thing that will Spring to many
people's minds is their mortgages right
yeah well mortgages unfortunately as we
know are high if anyone who's had to
refinance recently or has as you know
many many hundreds of thousands of
households do over the next 12 months
will have to refinance a fixed rate
mortgage today's news is not good for
mortgage holders indirectly because
higher inflation or rather persistently
stubbornly High inflation means that the
bank of England is likely to need to be
more assertive in keeping interest rates
higher for longer the markets now are
strongly predicting that the bank will
raise interest rates next month which
means bad news for mortgage holders I
mean the inflation thing it hits all of
us and it hits all of us in different
ways but it really hits hardest those on
the lowest incomes or on Lower incomes
because particularly for folks who have
less money to spend the proportion of
their household spending that is used up
on things like energy and food in
particular is much higher which means
that the really bad news today is not
just that inflation isn't coming down as
quickly as Andrew Bailey the governor
the bank of England was hoping it's the
underlying story is one in which food
inflation is particular is now at a
40-something year home it's the highest
ever been in my lifetime for sure I mean
it's it's scary when you when you look
at the figures a 45-year high we'll get
on to food inflation in just a in just a
sec Greg but just on mortgages and and
for homeowners obviously the majority of
people are on a fixed rate mortgage so
you're only going to be affected if your
mortgage is either coming up for Renewal
or you're one of a minority of
homeowners who has a variable rate
mortgage is that right yes that's right
if you're on a fixed rate deal today and
that fixed rate deal doesn't expire for
another 12 months fingers crossed by the
time you need to refinance interest
rates will have come down from their
current sort of relatively elevated
levels it's also be clear I mean
interest rates haven't risen today it's
just that the markets now expect that
they will need to rise next month when
the bank of England monetary policy
committee meets and announces the new
the new interest rates now it's not just
moon is is it Greg High mortgages
usually translates in higher rent as
well doesn't it it does it indirectly
feeds through and that's exactly what
we've been seeing we've been seeing
rents Rising very sharply rents Rising
not only of course because of high
mortgage rates but also rents Rising
because of high energy bills so
landlords who for instance landlords
aren't asking tenants to pay for their
for their energy use you're also going
to see those costs filter through and
generally landlords like all the rest of
us are fitting the squeeze and seeking
to pass on some of those costs where
they can as unfair as that feels if you
are renting right now let's talk about
food inflation which is eye-wateringly
high a 45-year high last month in fact
and this is the thing affecting many
people the most especially people on low
incomes Greg food has dramatically
increased in price put that in context
100 pound weekly shop not unusual for a
family of four that same basket of food
today would cost 100 19 pounds so it's
almost a 20 increase over the last 12
months in food prices and it's worse
than that particularly again for
families at the lower end of the income
spectrum because the foods that are
particularly increased in price
unfortunately are the Staples I was
looking at this earlier on olive oil has
increased over just the last 12 months
from a little over four pound for half a
liter to something like seven pounds for
half a liter so that's almost almost a
two times increase in the cost of
something pretty basic to cook with of
course there are other kinds of oil but
they've also increased in price peppers
have increased in price by more than
twofold Garden peas have increased in
price would you believe it from from 88p
for a you know a kilo of frozen peas
right the way up to more than two pounds
so that's nearly two and a half times
more expensive so this is the really
basic stuff that you've got to pull out
of the fridge or the Larder in order to
feed your kids has dramatically
increased in price and this is why even
behind the headline this rising cost of
food is it's a really hard blow for Hard
Rock families yeah as you say we're not
talking about luxury items we are
talking about the basics I'm looking at
a breakdown of costs here Greg whole
milk a four pint carton has gone up from
one pound 64 last year to two pounds 28
this year now
many families simply can't afford to pay
20 more for their food are we going to
see food inflation chill out and come
down anytime soon well you know the
problem is that the bank of England and
government sources have every incentive
to want to talk down inflation they
don't want us to expect inflation will
remain high because of course if we
expect it to remain high inflation's a
funny old thing the more people expect
it to remain high the more it will and
so yes we can hope that inflation does
start to come down including food
inflation as the year progresses
but even if inflation starts to fall
prices won't
inflation is not a measure of pricing
inflation is a measure of the rate at
which prices change so even if food
inflation were to halve by the end of
the year from 20 to 10 that doesn't mean
that the cost of pasta is going to come
down that just means that the rate at
which Pastor increases in price is going
to come down
right so for people who are already
struggling to afford their grocery shop
that's here to stay they're not going to
get lower prices in a few months time
once inflation reduces these prices
already baked in these prices are baked
in and it's really it's no surprise that
you've seen the highest levels of food
bank use for a generation it's no
surprise that families are cutting back
on eating out less and of course that
also has an effect on the real economy
that means that people buy less with
their money because their money doesn't
go as far as it used to so all of this
stuff compounds the risk that as a whole
the economy doesn't grow as fast as of
course the government wants it to but
businesses wants it to and that could in
turn lead to you know losses and jobs
and other things so it's it's not good
news there's very little good news today
I do appreciate the the powers that be
want us to look at the the Silver Lining
and there is as I say there is life at
the end of the tunnel in the food prices
Energy prices probably will come down or
rate of rate of increases the rate of
inflation
but I just think we have to brace
ourselves for an awful lot more pain and
suffering before that happens
okay so gurpreet it all sounds a bit
Doom and Gloom at the moment but as Greg
just said there is a bit of hope that
inflation could start to come down soon
right well we're already starting to see
that because some of the external
factors that we didn't have much control
over like the energy crisis are starting
to fade away now wholesale gas prices
are now lower than they were before the
war in Ukraine began in February last
year and that will filter through and
has filtered through into lower motor
fuel prices for example but also our
energy bills our household energy bills
are going to start coming down now when
the off gems energy cap Falls so it's
already starting to happen Okay so that
is some good news for people today and
how I mean you say that's already you
know impacting prices in terms of it
being passed on to Consumers how soon
are they going to really feel the
benefits of that well there are a couple
of mechanisms that are affecting our
household energy bills we have wholesale
prices we then also have the off gem
price cap which responds to those
wholesale prices changes in those
wholesale prices to set the amount that
energy companies can charge households
but we've also got the government's
price guarantee which is capping the
amount that energy companies can charge
taking all of that into consideration we
think around the summertime June and
July we should start seeing a material
drop in the amount that we're paying for
our household energy bills okay Greg I'm
going to give you the final word before
we go can you leave us with any positive
news or at least some advice on how to
weather this really difficult period
they're not Magic Bullets there is some
potentially good news coming through on
the uh so energy is a good example we
are now just beginning to see the first
signs that cheaper energy tariffs are
going to be introduced into the market
at one large lender has already
introduced them you can actually right
now save money on your energy if you
know where to look I run a business
called mouse.com hope that there might
be ways you can save money on your
energy using services like that but
beyond that unfortunately it's all the
same advice and much of it people have
already followed right I mean you can
save money in your energy by using less
of it by heating your home less but
that's not much fun and people have
already taken those steps you can save
money on your food by shopping from a
list shopping at the end of the day
avoiding convenience stores and buying o
brand lines and all those sensible
things but you know these are small beer
unfortunately for most families that are
hard up
my thanks to gopreet no one and Greg
Marsh and to you for listening to the
Sky News Daily with me Sally Lockwood
this episode was produced by Rosie
Gillett our editor is Philly Beaumont